shortly before 9 a.m.  fashion designer Gianni Versace was shot  on the steps of his bill pronounced  Versace a singer that's Liberace it was  a create he was a genius everything you  see around us this house this company  was his life I will not allow that man  that nobody to kill my brother twice  this what brings you to Miami  I know people oh yeah you're Sachi Sachi  yes of course you have no idea what do  you do for work  isn't that what are your greatest  attributes I'm smart I'm clever I was  thinking more along the lines of how  babe can't do it again you can't what  stop lying  Andrew Cunanan 27 years old he's killed  four men  this world is wasted me and that this  world also made you mr. Saji under a  star you're not better than me or the  same the only difference is that you got  lucky the assassination of Gianni  Versace premieres Wednesday January 17th  on FX  you